Selamat datang kembali di Quantum Computing in Practice. Ini adalah episode 6. Hari ini kita akan fokus pada salah satu
aplikasi favorit komputer kuantum menurutku, mensimulasikan alam. Di episode ini, kita akan membahas langkah-langkah yang diperlukan
untuk melakukan ini untuk semua jenis masalah dinamika kuantum, yaitu masalah menemukan bagaimana deskripsi suatu
sistem kuantum berubah seiring waktu. Kita akan melakukan ini di tingkat tinggi terlebih dahulu lalu melihat contoh spesifik dan
membahasnya secara detail. yaitu eksperimen IBM 2023 yang mendemonstrasikan quantum utility. Sebagai sedikit motivasi di
awal, salah satu kisah paling terkenal yang kita di bidang quantum computing ceritakan berulang kali,
kisah Richard Feynman memberikan kuliah di Caltech pada tahun 1959 dan pada dasarnya
memberikan motivasi untuk seluruh bidang ini selama beberapa dekade ke depan. Pidato itu disebut there's plenty of room at the
bottom. judul yang lucu, tapi ide dasarnya adalah dia mengklaim masih ada banyak fisika kaya yang bisa
ditemukan di tingkat mikroskopis.
Sekarang, kuliah spesifik itu tidak banyak diperhatikan sampai tahun 80-an ketika teknologi sudah berkembang cukup pesat. Dan Feynman
juga mengklarifikasi dan menyempurnakan pesannya dari waktu ke waktu. Dia kembali ke Caltech di tahun 80-an dan mempresentasikan makalah lain berjudul
simulating nature with computers di mana dia secara khusus mengatakan ingin membicarakan kemungkinan bahwa ada
simulasi yang tepat di mana komputer akan melakukan hal yang persis sama seperti yang dilakukan alam.
pada dasarnya bisa menghilangkan aproksimasi kasar dari apa yang terjadi di skala atom dan menggantinya dengan
komputer yang memahami dan memanfaatkan fisika kuantum tidak hanya untuk mensimulasikan apa yang dilakukan alam, tapi mengemulasikannya.
Sekarang, ingat grafik timeline yang aku tunjukkan di episode sebelumnya. Di satu ujung, kita punya masalah yang mudah
diselesaikan dan tidak akan memerlukan percepatan apa pun yang bisa ditawarkan kuantum. Tapi di ujung lain, kita punya masalah yang
sangat sulit dan membutuhkan mesin kuantum toleran kesalahan yang belum kita miliki.
Beruntungnya, kita percaya ada cukup banyak masalah simulasi yang berada di tengah, yaitu wilayah yang
saat ini bisa kita kerjakan. Dan ada banyak alasan untuk antusias dan tertarik dengan prospek ini karena
simulasi alam adalah dasar dari banyak area aplikasi yang menarik. hanya untuk menyebut beberapa. Kalau kita bisa lebih baik
mensimulasikan alam, kita bisa mempercepat penemuan material baru, menciptakan farmasi dan obat yang lebih baik, atau
bahkan menjelajahi fisika baru yang mendasari fisika partikel atau kosmologi. Tapi sebelum kamu atau aku atau siapa pun bisa mencoba
menerapkan quantum computing pada area-area menarik ini untuk saat ini, mereka perlu memahami langkah-langkah dasar dalam
alur kerja berbasis simulasi yang khas.
Pertama, kamu perlu mengidentifikasi sistem kuantum yang diminati. Ini akan memberi informasi tentang Hamiltonian yang mengatur evolusi
waktunya dan deskripsi yang bermakna tentang properti awal atau statenya.
Kemudian kamu perlu menemukan metode yang tepat untuk mengimplementasikan evolusi waktu dari state ini. Dengan bahan-bahan ini
yang sudah diatur, langkah-langkah berikutnya melibatkan pelaksanaan eksperimen yang sebenarnya.
Ini umumnya melibatkan optimasi implementasi quantum circuit dari algoritma evolusi waktu, mengeksekusi
circuit atau circuit-circuit pada hardware kuantum dan pasca-pemrosesan hasilnya. Jadi kita
bisa menyebutkan langkah-langkah dasar yang terlibat dalam eksperimen simulasi sebagai berikut.
Mengidentifikasi Hamiltonian sistem, pengkodean Hamiltonian, persiapan state, evolusi state,
optimasi circuit, eksekusi circuit, dan pasca-pemrosesan.
Tapi ini adalah langkah-langkah yang cukup detail. Ingat bahwa empat tahap dari kerangka Qiskit patterns, yang membantu
kita memahami cara mengimplementasikan rutinitas dalam Qiskit adalah pemetaan, optimasi circuit, eksekusi circuit, dan
pasca-pemrosesan. Jadi empat langkah pertama di sini sebenarnya semuanya termasuk di bawah payung pemetaan dan itulah
kenapa kita menghabiskan seluruh episode untuk tahap pertama ini dan kalau kamu melewatkannya silakan kembali dan tonton episode sebelumnya.
Sekarang mari kita telusuri dulu apa arti langkah-langkah ini sebelum kita mendalami pengkodean apa pun. Jadi hal pertama yang perlu
kita lakukan untuk melakukan eksperimen simulasi adalah mengidentifikasi Hamiltonian yang mendeskripsikan sistem. Terkadang
seringkali ini sudah diketahui, di lain waktu kita harus menyusunnya dari pemahaman kontribusi energi
subset kecil dari sistem penuh seperti ini di mana hi adalah Hamiltonian yang bekerja pada salah satu dari n subsistem h.
Kita juga perlu memperhatikan apakah sistem terdiri dari fermion atau boson jika kita berhadapan dengan partikel elementer. Berikutnya,
kita perlu mengkodekan Hamiltonian dan menerjemahkannya ke dalam istilah yang bisa dipahami komputer kuantum. Seringkali,
Hamiltonian-Hamiltonian ini akan terdiri dari partikel elementer atau sistem spin. Kalau kita mensimulasikan fermion atau boson, kita
perlu memilih transformasi pengkodean seperti Jordan Wigner atau Bravyi Kitaev. Transformasi-transformasi ini akan
memberitahu kita cara menerjemahkan definisi Hamiltonian yang ditulis dalam hal komponen aslinya. fermion atau
boson menjadi operator Pauli yang mudah dikonversi menjadi gate pada komputer kuantum. Misalnya, transformasi Jordan Wigner
yang didefinisikan di sini memberikan pemetaan dari operator fermion ke operator Pauli. Kalau kita sudah berhadapan
dengan sistem spin 1/2 yang sangat umum maka kita sudah siap selain dari koefisien normalisasi yang mungkin ada
dan kita tidak perlu menggunakan skema pengkodean. Setelah mengkodekan Hamiltonian yang diinginkan ke dalam
set gate komputer kuantum, langkah penting berikutnya adalah menentukan quantum state awal yang tepat dari mana kita memulai
simulasi. State ini idealnya harus mencerminkan beberapa makna fisik atau konfigurasi
sistem yang sedang dipelajari. Misalnya, kalau kita tertarik menjelajahi energi ground state molekul, kita mungkin
mulai dengan aproksimasi Hartree-Fock atau ansatz yang mudah disiapkan lainnya yang memiliki overlap signifikan dengan ground state
yang sebenarnya. Pilihan ground state awal mempengaruhi tidak hanya konvergensi algoritma variasional
seperti VQE variational quantum eigensolver tapi juga akurasi dan efisiensi
evolusi waktu atau sampling dalam quantum phase estimation. Pada intinya, state awal berfungsi sebagai
titik peluncuran untuk komputasi yang menyiapkan panggung untuk mengekstrak observable yang berguna tentang sistem kuantum
yang kita modelkan. persiapan state n qubit sembarang di mana ci adalah state basis komputasi dan ai adalah
WEBVTT
koefisien masing-masing state dan kondisi normalisasi 2 n dikurangi satu secara umum bisa didekati dengan
menginisialisasi state dengan operator o state awal akan menjadi state basis standar semua nol yang sering ditulis
seperti ini untuk penyederhanaan secara umum ini membutuhkan jumlah gate C not yang eksponensial seringkali kita
tertarik pada state awal yang spesifik untuk sistem dan persiapannya bisa diimplementasikan dengan jumlah
sumber daya yang wajar. State produk misalnya di mana qubit tidak saling terjerat hanya membutuhkan operasi
qubit tunggal. Sekarang kita sebenarnya belum punya kesempatan untuk membicarakan trotterisasi
meski beberapa dari kalian mungkin sudah familiar dengannya. Pada intinya, trotterisasi adalah metode untuk menghitung eksponensiasi matriks yang
menggunakan aproksimasi untuk menangani sifat eksponensial dari operator yang tidak komutasi. Ketika dua operator seperti HA
dan HB tidak komutasi, maka kita harus menerapkan trik yang cerdas dan secara bergantian menerapkan eksponensial
yang sesuai dari e pangkat -i ha dan e pangkat -i hb sebanyak n
kali. operator evolusi bergantian diterapkan. Aku tidak akan menjelaskan buktinya di sini, tapi aku akan membagikan tautan
ke bukti sederhana yang bagus untuk pernyataan ini dalam deskripsi. Tapi pesan utamanya adalah ini. Evolusi waktu adalah
bagian penting dari pemetaan juga. Trotterisasi memecah interaksi kontinu menjadi langkah-langkah diskrit yang bisa
diimplementasikan pada komputer kuantum. Setelah menghasilkan circuit yang di-trotterisasi, kita akhirnya selesai dengan
langkah pemetaan. Sekarang kita bisa melanjutkan ke optimasi circuit.
Untuk itu, ini yang perlu diselesaikan. Perlu ada tata letak qubit yang memetakan qubit virtual dari
circuit kamu ke qubit fisik pada hardware. Ini diperlukan karena hardware bisa memiliki topologi tertentu
yang membatasi interaksi langsung qubit fisik. Sementara implementasi
quantum circuit seringkali mengasumsikan kemampuan qubit mana pun untuk berinteraksi dengan qubit lainnya. Kemudian kita perlu menyisipkan
swap gate sesuai kebutuhan untuk merutekan interaksi antara qubit yang tidak terhubung. Kita perlu menerjemahkan
gate-gate dalam circuit kita ke instruksi instruction set architecture atau ISA yang
bisa langsung dieksekusi pada hardware. Kemudian kita perlu melakukan optimasi circuit untuk meminimalkan
kedalaman circuit dan jumlah gate. Langkah ini juga bisa dilakukan pada circuit virtual. Circuit di mana qubit
belum dipetakan ke topologi perangkat. Tapi ingat banyak dari ini dilakukan secara otomatis untukmu dalam
Qiskit. Kita akan melihat tepatnya bagaimana di bagian berikutnya dari kuliah ini. Setelah langkah optimasi, kita siap untuk menjalankan
circuit menggunakan sebuah primitive. Untuk sebagian besar eksperimen simulasi, kamu tertarik untuk memahami perubahan
sifat-sifat tertentu dari sistem seiring waktu. Jadi kemungkinan kamu akan menggunakan estimator primitive karena itu
akan memungkinkan kamu mengukur nilai ekspektasi observable yang sesuai dengan sifat-sifat spesifik. Kemudian kita akan
mengkonfigurasi opsi terbaik untuk estimator yang bisa menambahkan teknik penekanan kesalahan dan mitigasi kesalahan. Akhirnya, kita akan menjalankan
eksperimen. Langkah terakhir adalah pasca-pemrosesan semua data. Ini mengekstrak nilai ekspektasi yang diukur atau jika
kamu menggunakan sampler, distribusi probabilitas sampel dalam basis komputasi. Kalau yang dibutuhkan
hanyalah nilai ekspektasi dari observable yang diminati, ini bisa langsung diperoleh dari estimator
primitive baik dalam nilai mentah maupun nilai yang sudah dimitigasi kesalahannya. Seringkali seseorang kemudian akan menggunakan nilai ekspektasi yang diukur
untuk perhitungan lain untuk kuantitas lain yang diminati yang tidak memerlukan komputasi kuantum dan bisa
dihitung pada komputer klasik.
Sekarang kita akan menelusuri contoh nyata dari makalah yang sangat berpengaruh yang diterbitkan IBM beberapa tahun lalu berjudul
evidence for utility of quantum computing before fault tolerance. Nah, makalah ini yang kita singkat dengan sayang sebagai
utility paper menjadi makalah yang sangat berpengaruh di bidang quantum computing hampir segera setelah dipublikasikan.
Tesis keseluruhan makalah ini adalah bahwa komputer kuantum yang berisik menghasilkan hasil yang akurat atau nilai ekspektasi
menggunakan 127 qubit dan 2.880 gate di luar kemampuan komputasi brute
force yang merupakan simulasi eksak dari circuit kuantum yang dieksekusi oleh hardware. Pekerjaan ini juga
penting karena menunjukkan bahwa komputer kuantum bisa digunakan untuk memverifikasi atau membandingkan hasil dengan metode klasik
aproksimasi lain untuk simulasi kuantum seperti algoritma tensor network di mana solusinya
tidak diketahui sebelumnya. Yang juga cukup keren adalah sekarang orang lain menggunakan sistem IBM quantum di
cloud dan Qiskit bisa menduplikasi dan memverifikasi hasil ini sendiri.
Aku akan memandu kamu cara melakukan itu. Jadi untuk contoh ini, kita akan sedikit lebih spesifik tentang
langkah-langkah yang terlibat dalam memetakan masalah ini menjadi input yang bisa dipahami perangkat kuantum. Dalam hal ini, kita akan
mensimulasikan dinamika total magnetisasi sistem dari spin dipol magnetik pada kisi dalam
kehadiran medan magnet eksternal. Sistem ini bisa dideskripsikan oleh model Ising dengan medan magnet transversal.
Kita memodelkan ini dengan parameterized quantum circuit di mana parameternya sesuai dengan nilai yang bisa disesuaikan dari
interaksi spin-spin atau z dan kekuatan medan magnet X. Sekarang,
seri ini disebut quantum computing in practice. Jadi, kita juga akan membahas prosedur dalam eksperimen ini
yang akan kita implementasikan untuk membuat hasil sebaik mungkin. Jadi berikutnya kita akan membahas cara menghapus
qubit yang buruk atau qubit dengan fidelitas gate yang rendah atau waktu dekoheren yang bisa sangat mempengaruhi
hasil eksperimen. qubit yang buruk ini bisa terjadi karena kalibrasi sebelumnya yang buruk
atau sistem dua-level yang berinteraksi dengan qubit. Menghapus beberapa qubit dari topologi native hardware sesuai dengan
mempertimbangkan sistem pada kisi yang dideskripsikan oleh topologi yang dihasilkan. Kita juga akan membahas pembuatan
parameterized quantum circuit yang mengimplementasikan evolusi waktu sistem melalui trotterisasi.
Untuk tujuan ini, penting untuk mengidentifikasi lapisan-lapisan entangling yang merupakan bagian kritis untuk teknik mitigasi kesalahan utama
yang akan kita gunakan nanti. Jadi pada titik ini aku ingin memastikan bahwa kamu penonton tahu
bahwa kamu bisa mengikuti semua yang akan aku bahas dalam tutorial yang tertaut di bawah dan di platform
WEBVTT
IBM quantum learning. Dalam tutorial ini, yang mungkin kamu perhatikan adalah kita sudah membuat serangkaian fungsi pembantu
di awal notebook yang bisa kita panggil nanti untuk membuat hidup kita sedikit lebih mudah. Aku ingin menyebutkan ini
sekarang, bukan karena itu bagian dari proses resmi atau formal, tapi karena ini sering yang dilakukan eksperimentalis
di kehidupan nyata untuk membantu mereka menjalankan jenis eksperimen ini. Dan ini juga menunjukkan kepada kita bagaimana kita akan memecah
masalah kita lebih jauh lagi. Fungsi-fungsi yang kita definisikan dalam notebook adalah sebagai berikut. Remove qubit couplings.
Define qubit couplings. Construct the layer couplings. Construct entangling layers. Dan terakhir, define trotterized
circuit. Berikutnya, mari kita bicara tentang layer couplings, yang membantu mendefinisikan bagaimana qubit
berinteraksi dengan tetangganya selama simulasi. Perangkat kuantum kita menggunakan sesuatu yang disebut tata letak
heavy hexagonal. Pola khusus untuk menghubungkan qubit. Dalam tata letak ini, kita bisa mengelompokkan koneksi yang disebut tepi menjadi tiga
set terpisah di mana tidak ada dua koneksi dalam set yang sama berbagi qubit. Ini
penting karena pada komputer kuantum yang nyata, kita tidak bisa menjalankan dua gate qubit pada waktu yang sama jika keduanya melibatkan
qubit yang sama. Setiap qubit hanya bisa terlibat dalam satu gate pada satu waktu. Dengan
membagi semua koneksi menjadi tiga lapisan, kita bisa menerapkan dua gate qubit di seluruh perangkat dalam tiga
putaran, memastikan tidak ada qubit yang digunakan dalam lebih dari satu gate per lapisan. Gate-gate
ini mengimplementasikan interaksi ZZ dari model Ising, dan diulang di setiap langkah simulasi yang disebut langkah
Trotter. twirling memodifikasi noise dalam perangkat sehingga bahkan model noise sederhana pun
kemungkinan besar akurat. Ini juga memungkinkan untuk belajar secara akurat tentang model noise dan menggunakan informasi yang diperoleh
dalam teknik mitigasi kesalahan.
Berikutnya, kita harus menghapus qubit yang buruk dari daftar qubit fisik yang mungkin bisa kita gunakan untuk
eksperimen. Seperti yang aku bilang, qubit bisa menjadi buruk karena berbagai alasan yang berbeda. Terkadang itu hanya
kalibrasi yang buruk, kesalahan sederhana yang bisa diselesaikan hanya dengan kalibrasi ulang.
Terkadang lebih rumit dan berkaitan dengan apa yang kita sebut TLS, yaitu cacat antar muka dua-level yang
menyebabkan fluktuasi parameter qubit dan relaksasi. Ini bisa
diselesaikan dengan memanaskan seluruh sistem sedikit dan kemudian mendinginkannya kembali. Tapi itu butuh waktu dan tidak memungkinkan untuk
dilakukan melalui cloud. Jadi untuk saat ini, hal termudah yang bisa dilakukan adalah hanya mengecualikan mereka dari daftar qubit fisik
yang akan kita gunakan. Kamu bisa mengidentifikasi qubit mana yang tidak berperilaku sesuai harapan dengan mudah dari platform IBM quantum.
Kamu bisa memplot karakteristik qubit di sana dalam platform atau mengunduhnya sebagai CSV. Kemudian buat daftar semua
qubit yang ingin kamu kecualikan dan hapus saja dari daftar total qubit fisik pada perangkat.
Oke. Sekarang mari kita lanjutkan dengan langkah pemetaan kita menghasilkan circuit yang di-trotterisasi. Seperti yang kita tunjukkan
sebelumnya trotterisasi mendiskritisasi evolusi waktu menjadi serangkaian langkah dan kita perlu memutuskan berapa banyak langkah.
Kita pilih enam di sini. Tapi secara umum strateginya adalah menyeimbangkan sesuatu yang disebut Trotter error yang merupakan
kesalahan aproksimasi algoritmik dengan kesalahan yang timbul dari dekoheren. Lebih banyak langkah Trotter mengurangi kesalahan aproksimasi
tapi membutuhkan circuit kuantum yang lebih dalam yang mengalami lebih banyak noise dari dekoheren. Kita akan mendefinisikan
circuit dalam hal parameter theta yang merupakan kekuatan lapisan layer couplings medan magnet eksternal dan
jumlah langkah dan qubit dan tentu saja backend perangkat. Karena
ketergantungan magnetisasi sistem pada kekuatan medan magnet eksternal, menarik untuk
mengeksekusi simulasi pada berbagai nilai kekuatan medan magnet yang diterjemahkan menjadi sudut RX yang berbeda pada
rotasi untuk RX dalam circuit. Sekarang setelah menghasilkan circuit kita, kita akan melanjutkan ke optimasinya.
Langkah pertama di sini adalah mendefinisikan pass manager. Ingat dalam konteks Qiskit SDK, transpilasi mengacu pada
proses mengubah circuit input menjadi bentuk yang cocok untuk eksekusi pada perangkat kuantum.
Transpilasi biasanya terjadi dalam urutan langkah yang disebut transpiler passes. Pass manager adalah objek yang
menyimpan daftar transpiler passes dan bisa mengeksekusinya pada sebuah circuit. buat pass manager dengan menginisialisasi objek pass
manager dengan daftar transpiler passes. Pada akhirnya, pass manager kita
akan membuat ISA circuit, sebuah circuit yang harus ditulis dalam hal instruction set architecture backend,
yang mendeskripsikan circuit dan gate yang native untuk backend tapi tidak memiliki informasi timing yang diperlukan untuk menjalankan
circuit. Sekarang kita siap untuk mengeksekusi circuit kita yang merupakan langkah ketiga dari Qiskit patterns. Seperti yang disebutkan sebelumnya kita pasti akan
menggunakan estimator di sini sebagai primitive pilihan kita untuk eksperimen ini karena kita ingin mengukur
total magnetisasi sistem dan mengestimasi nilai ekspektasi observable adalah untuk apa estimator
dirancang. Dalam langkah ini juga akan sangat penting untuk menentukan opsi kita untuk mitigasi kesalahan. Kita akan menggunakan zero noise
extrapolation untuk mendapatkan hasil terbaik yang mungkin. Khususnya dalam tutorial, kamu akan melihat bahwa kita menentukan dua atau lebih
nilai faktor noise untuk mengevaluasi model ekstrapolasi dan menentukan
probabilistic error amplification sebagai opsi amplifikasi kita. Sekarang, probabilistic
error amplification atau PA benar-benar metode teknik mitigasi kesalahan yang menjadi pilihan di sini karena skalanya jauh
lebih baik dari pilihan lainnya. Dan itulah yang penting ketika kita bekerja di level 100 plus qubit.
Terakhir tapi tidak kalah penting, jalankan eksperimen dan ini akan membutuhkan beberapa waktu untuk selesai, tapi untuk sekarang, mari kita referensikan data yang
sudah antri dan disimpan dari tutorial. Kita akan memeriksa metadata dengan mencatat secara khusus layered gates dan
mitigated layers karena kita akan menggunakannya untuk menghapus banyak kesalahan dari data mentah kita. Kita hampir siap
untuk memplot hasil akhir kita. Tapi sebelum kita melakukan itu, mari kita cepat tambahkan selingan di sini tentang apa yang sebenarnya dimaksud dengan zero
noise extrapolation atau ZNE. Kita sudah membahasnya secara singkat di episode sebelumnya, tapi untuk mengulas, zero noise extrapolation
adalah teknik mitigasi kesalahan yang menghilangkan efek noise yang tidak diketahui selama eksekusi circuit yang bisa
diskalakan dengan cara yang diketahui. Ini mengasumsikan nilai ekspektasi berskala dengan noise oleh fungsi yang diketahui yang ditampilkan di sini di mana
WEBVTT
parameter lambda menentukan kekuatan noise dan bisa diperkuat. Kita bisa mengimplementasikan ZNE dengan langkah-langkah berikut.
Pertama, perkuat noise circuit untuk beberapa faktor noise. Lambda 1, lambda 2,
lambda 3, dan seterusnya. Jalankan setiap circuit yang diperkuat noise untuk mengukur
nilai ekspektasi a dari lambda 1, a dari lambda 2, dan seterusnya. Dan kemudian ekstrapolasikan kembali ke batas
zero noise, nilai ekspektasi a dari nol.
Tantangan utama dalam mengimplementasikan ZNE dengan sukses adalah memiliki model yang akurat untuk noise dalam nilai ekspektasi
dan memperkuat noise dengan cara yang diketahui.
Ada tiga cara umum amplifikasi kesalahan diimplementasikan untuk ZNE: skalakan durasi pulsa melalui kalibrasi,
ulangi gate dalam siklus identitas, dan tambahkan noise melalui sampling saluran Pauli.
Kita menyebut yang terakhir PA. Probabilistic error amplification adalah pilihan terbaik di sini karena pulse stretching sangat
mahal secara komputasi. Gate folding tidak memiliki jaminan teoritis dalam menjaga bias noise. Tapi PA bisa
diterapkan ke circuit mana pun yang bisa dijalankan dengan faktor noise native tapi membutuhkan pembelajaran model noise. PA mengasumsikan
model noise berbasis lapisan yang sama seperti probabilistic error cancellation.
Namun, ini menghindari overhead sampling yang berskala secara eksponensial dengan noise circuit. Untuk mempelajari model noise,
kita harus terlebih dahulu mengidentifikasi lapisan unik dari operasi dua qubit dalam circuit.
Untuk setiap lapisan, lakukan Pauli twirl pada gate dua qubit untuk memastikan noise terdeskripsi dengan baik oleh model noise damping.
ulangi pasangan identitas lapisan pada kedalaman yang bervariasi dan akhirnya sesuaikan fidelitas atau kesalahan untuk setiap saluran noise. Dan
tentu saja, meskipun aku merekomendasikan memahami metode ini sampai tingkat tertentu, melakukannya secara manual di Qiskit adalah
jauh lebih sederhana seperti yang ditunjukkan dalam tutorial. Sekarang, akhirnya, mari kita lihat data yang diplotkan. Garis
abu-abu putus-putus menunjukkan hasil eksak yang diperoleh dengan metode klasik aproksimasi dengan kesalahan aproksimasi
yang konvergen ke ambang yang rendah. Seperti yang bisa kamu lihat, data mentah untuk faktor noise berbeda yang kita pilih di
awal cukup jauh dari garis putus-putus ini. Garis biru solid menunjukkan data dengan mempertimbangkan pemrosesan ZNE
kita. Dan kamu bisa langsung bilang itu jauh lebih dekat ke hasil eksak.
Sebagai ringkasan, nilai yang berisik menunjukkan deviasi tinggi dari nilai eksak. Nilai yang
sudah dimitigasi mendekati nilai eksak, mendemonstrasikan utilitas dari teknik mitigasi berbasis PA.
Dan itu pada dasarnya menyimpulkan episode ini. Untuk merangkum secara cepat apa yang sudah kita pelajari, simulasi kuantum adalah salah satu
area aplikasi yang paling menjanjikan dalam jangka pendek hingga menengah.
Ini memiliki aplikasi yang luas mulai dari farmasi hingga fisika energi tinggi,
ilmu material dan lainnya. Utility paper dari IBM yang diterbitkan pada tahun 2023
menunjukkan jalan menuju kemampuan menggunakan komputer kuantum untuk penemuan ilmiah. Dan kita menelusuri
tutorial yang terkait dengan makalah tersebut secara mendalam. Langkah-langkah untuk mengerjakan masalah simulasi dari awal
hingga selesai relatif mudah, terutama setelah kamu sudah terbiasa. Dan harapanku adalah kamu
mulai sekarang bisa menggunakan video ini dan tutorial sebagai panduan untuk masalah simulasi yang lebih banyak di masa depan.
Terima kasih sudah menonton dan sampai jumpa lain kali di Quantum Computing in Practice.